No the data science and artificial
intelligence have a lot in common.
Everything we just heard
from Dave was about
building models to understand data.
Artificial intelligence as Sebastian and
Ashok described was about intelligently
reacting to incoming data.
If you recall the axis that Ashok drew,
in machine learning we're interested
specifically in thinking optimally.
We don't necessarily want to design
systems that think the way we do.
We want to design systems
that think better than we do.
At least in some ways.
We want to design systems that
can learn from much larger
quantities of data much
more quickly than we can.
That's why we covered Bayes' Rule
in data science here as well.
Machine learning is largely about
looking at the data we have and learning
the mechanisms that gave rise to it
are learning the models that explain it.
So let's move on to
machine learning itself.
Let's start by hearing from Sebastian
through and Katie Malone for
you to ask these own
machine learning class.